[Music]
jake is in dallas texas hi jake how are
you
doing great how are you guys doing
better than i deserve what's up
happy to hear it so i'm currently i'm 22
years old i'm self-employed
and i'm getting to a point where i
really want to start paying off on my
debt
building up a retirement plan and just
you know overall being more wise and
more strict with my budgeting
however i'm self-employed so my income
varies although it is steady
um but i just wanted to see what you
would recommend uh as
a method to build a budget when you are
self-employed and the money doesn't come
in as consistently
but you just want to stick to that
budget and be as efficient with your
money as possible
so what's your taxable income in 2021
uh 2021 i would estimate my personal
taxable income
around 80 000. good for you well done
what are you doing
what kind of business i do a lot of
post-production work
uh remotely for different film
production companies
around the world okay any employees
no it's just me good for you well done
well done
well i i think the the biggest thing is
not uh
how to attack the debt you're going to
attack the debt just like anyone else
would with your income
working the debt snowball right smallest
to largest and get after it in that
order
okay the question is how to manage the
irregular income
the first thing i would do is go get
ramsey plus and get a free membership
a free trial membership going and get
the every dollar premium version going
because the every dollar app will help
you do this what you can do is just you
can just go in and adjust it as your
income moves around
uh and so that's fairly easy way to do
it old school
the principle that you want to use even
when you're using the everydollar app
is a prioritized spending plan
okay now what that sounds like is this
uh in your case
uh you have a a fairly predictable
stream of income
but if we wanted to go all the way to
zero we could start with and say okay if
i can only afford to do
one thing this month what's that one
thing and you put a number one beside
that on your budget that's food by the
way
okay if i can only afford to do one
other thing what would i do and you put
a two beside that i'll tell you what
that is it's utilities
because if you eat and keep the lights
on you can deal with the landlord later
okay worst case scenario but you're not
even that far down you said you have
steady it's just unpredictable
correct and sometimes it's irregular in
terms of when the money comes
in but just wanting to so anyway you go
all the way down that list
and when you get towards the bottom of
that list is where the action takes
place in your world
and that is that you know when you get
to number 16
you do 16 before you do 17 and you put
the debt snowball stuff
in those bottom the extra money on debt
moves down after you've taken care of
the necessities of life
okay and they're ahead of going on
vacation because you're in baby step two
you're not going on vacation
right right and they're ahead of going
out to eat because you're in baby step
two and you're not going out to eat
how much debt are you in right now jake
um if you don't i just bought a house um
excluding the house
i would guess business about seven
thousand uh business debt and then
about twenty thousand personal debt
including my vehicle
including as far as your vehicle is
inside the twenty thousand dollars
correct okay what kind of vehicle is it
uh it's a forerunner toyota full runner
it's just it's big enough and
efficient enough for what i need you can
afford to do
every bit of thing what you're doing you
just need to get paid off and so 27
thousand dollars makes you debt-free
accept your house
correct you make 80 and you're single
and 22.
i'm married okay what's she make
uh so she is also kind of in between
jobs right now we're looking
to move kind of closer to back home with
family uh so her income fluctuates a
little bit but
roughly two thousand a month later right
now okay so you got a hundred thousand
dollar income you have twenty seven
thousand dollars in debt
you pay off your 27 000 inside of one
year
absolutely that's good
2500 to 3 000 a month at least towards
this debt
boom smack it in the head now that's
assuming a steady flow of this income
and it's not a real volatile income but
that should be the average over the 12
months you should be debt-free in
12 months easy really a little sooner
actually but the key ingredient to this
dave is what you said earlier he has to
get on the budget
he has to literally sit down and write
out his priorities
yeah if you do not do that you will not
get out of debt
because you're not going to know where
your money's going so sit down with your
wife
and y'all figure this thing out and i
heard you say you you may want to be
moving
soon i would focus on this before i move
so that way you're not even more
unstable go ahead and get out of debt
then let's talk about moving after we
get out of debt
that's that's not a bad idea at all